emu and Chef
is this the those Liberty mutualism help
stop driver fleeing crash site uh said
he could see the driver who appeared
drunk he said the man was determined to
escape heading off on foot Wade chased
the driver through bushes allotments and
Gardens before the pair ended up in an
animal sanctuary oh my God this is
really emu comes with the email I
thought the emo was just cruising around
I did too they said you could tell the
bird which was surrounded by its
Offspring was likely to spring into
defense if anyone came into the
enclosure he said mate don't go in there
who had ignored his advice because let's
face it he just crashed into a
storefront this guy's quote is maybe
quote of the year I can fight emus
that's what he said before heading into
the animals pen where he was repeatedly
packed causing the man to curse and
unsuccessful that would hurt
unsuccessfully attempt to Kung Fu kick
the animal while Wade took the
opportunity to flag down a nearby police